[Music]
art is not supposed to change the world
but art can change the way we see
the world
so now my wish is
for you
to stand up
for what you care about
by participating in a global art project
and together
we turn the world
inside out
they had a big idea to change the world
but they couldn't do it alone
so my wish by my wish i wish so not my
wish and now
here's my wish
[Music]
my name is jr i like to call myself an
artist
there's two ways of thinking about my
work the easy way is just i'm papering
black and white images on walls
but i believe my work is about
connecting people
for me it's the power of bringing people
together
i went there to do art projects with the
community now i realized that the
community wanted to do art projects even
more than i wanted and
start thinking why don't i take myself
off the equation and let them do it
so the wish was pretty simple is you
just put up a website and you can send
us your photo for whatever you believe
in or whatever you want to fight for
we'll send you back
your photo in large format wherever you
are in the world
every day i see roles living
around the world
[Applause]
the project went much further than the
places i've been and that shows the
power of art and photo booth struck is
the magic of it
[Music]
we're a team of four traveling in the
photo booth truck josh basil jamie and i
to pose we should look like this
we are using two of these trucks to
cover 30 cities around america
we're just a tool for people that want
to send a positive message
step inside and take a seat over here
once the truck is ready and running
anyone can come
[Music]
wait for the flash
that's the screen take your picture type
your information
in a matter of minutes or so
it prints on the side three by four feet
no one is used to seeing their faces so
big
oh yeah there's my funny face for ya the
truck has this magic about bringing
photography back to the print
then the posters go to the wall
we use wallpaper glue put them up and
that's it
[Music]
we printed more than 300 000 faces
already
and we sent them to more than 130
countries
[Music]
it's the people's art projects
we don't decide the message it can be
political to bring attention to issues i
love the idea of using photography to
promote change
this specific project is to raise
awareness about the dreamers situation
[Music]
inside out is bringing the opportunity
for dreamers like myself a person that
came here a young age to have a better
future to come out and give a face to
the issue
when people drive by and they see a lot
of faces they're going to get curious
and they're going to wonder
who they are
that's the face to the issue
dehumanize it
[Music]
you do think that just pasting an image
up there might have no impact but it
does have an impact you cannot know when
and how but it was trying
all starts with believing right so if
you don't believe that you can make
change
change will never happen even if it's a
very small change in one person that's
positive change
this is not about jr anymore it's about
everyone that believes that art can
change the world
i think that definitely art can change
the perception we have about the world
and if we start seeing the world
differently
maybe it's a good path to start changing
the world
[Music]
[Music]
you